Escribe un polinomio que exprese el valor total de "p" billetes de 20 pesos
"q" monedas de 10 pesos y
"r2 monedas de 5 pesos.
¿Ok? Entonces tenemos "p" billetes de 20 pesos y ¿Cuántos pesos valen esos "p" billetes de 20 pesos?
Pues como tenemos "p" billetes vamos a poner por aquí una "p" y cada uno de esos billetes vale
20 pesos ¿Ok? Entonces en total todos esos billetes juntos valen 20 por "p" pesos.
Ahora pasemos a las "q" monedas de 10 pesos y es exactamente lo mismo.
Tenemos por aquí "q" monedas y cada una de esas monedas vale 10 pesos.
Entonces para encontrar el valor total de esas "q" monedas lo que tenemos que hacer es multiplicar
"q" por 10
por que tenemos "q" monedas que valen 10 y lo mismo pasa con las "r" monedas de 5 pesos.
Cada moneda vale 5 pesos y tenemos
"r" de ellas.
Entonces en total todas estas juntas valen 5 por "r" y pues nos piden el valor total.
Así es que si tenemos 20 por "p" pesos en billetes de 20 pesos
y 10 por "q" pesos en monedas de 10 pesos
entonces en total tenemos 20 por "p" pesos más
10 por "q" pesos.
¿Ok? Pero también tenemos "r" monedas de 5 pesos, así es que también tenemos que sumarlas,
y pues eso es todo. Este es
tal cual el polinomio que nos pidieron.
Polinomio lo único que significa es que son varios términos ¿Ok? De hecho podríamos decir que este es un trinomio por que tiene tres términos
pero, bueno esto expresa el valor total de nuestros billetes y monedas.